how's it going reject nation greg and
john here today we're going to watch
from our buddy warren from the cosmic
wonder major marvel trailers update
spider-man know what home hawkeye
turtles don't perceive miss marvel whole
bunch i have to leave in about 90
minutes to go pick up warren from the
airport we are going to go watch chongqi
tonight at the premiere and i told him
yeah sure i'll pick you up put a dent in
my day
so figured yeah let's watch the cause of
wonder video hear his voice that way i
could see his face later on in the
passenger seat of my car be like whoa
you're here let's go
what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and
today i have a quick video for you in
regards to a bunch of upcoming trailers
not just the spider-man far from home
one which of course we are going to talk
about no way hold on miss marvel
and doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness side note tonight i will be
attending the red carpet world premiere
of xiangxi and the legend of the 10
rings in la with my buddies the real
rejects greg
and we are allowed to post our reaction
immediately after watching the movie so
be sure to stay tuned to see what we
thought about shanghi and the legend of
the tin rings that's gonna be going on
our channel right yeah it has to go
underneath you're going on your channel
you have enough news and scoops man are
we gonna be in the same video we're in
the same video together we put our video
on his channel and his video on our
channel
so obviously we have to start with
spider-man far from home and some of you
may have heard this but for those of you
who didn't things are actually getting
pretty interesting and looking pretty
good for a spider-man trailer relatively
soon according to a few different
sources right now the trailer for
spider-man no way home right now is
being dubbed in india this is great news
on a couple different levels
it means that the trailer is actually
done and this is something that we
actually were wondering about because
they are currently still doing reshoots
for spider-man no way home and we didn't
really know if these reshoots had to be
done before they actually completed the
trailer but they wouldn't have begun to
dub it in india if it wasn't already
done because they need the whole thing
obviously and for those of you who are
unaware of what dubbing it means it
means the voice actors are recording
their parts in hindi and this means that
it's most likely going to be done in
other languages pretty soon as well so
again good news that means it's
completed and the other good news is of
course this puts us closer to actually
getting the release of the trailer the
good part about that too is because
there's a lot of speculation that
they're at least going to be showing
some type of trailer or footage at a
cinemacon but if they are dubbing it
that means they are prepping for a
worldwide release of the trailer itself
and not just a solely distributed like
isolated moment to show audiences in las
vegas they're setting us up for an
actual worldwide release of the trailer
there had been reports and rumors that
it was going to come out before what if
that obviously wasn't true and over the
past week or so we were all pretty much
concerned that they weren't released in
the trailer because they might be
thinking about delaying the release date
of spider-man knowing home just like
they recently did with venom let there
be carnage now the good news is venom 2
was only delayed a few weeks not a month
or a few months only a few weeks so if
they truly were thinking about pushing
back the release date of no way home
they're probably only going to push it
back a little which would only delay the
trailer just a little bit as well but as
of right now we are pretty much almost
exactly four months away from the actual
movie's release and four months out is
usually when they released the teaser
trailer sony did this for venom let
there be carnage then two months later
they followed it up with the official
full-length trailer but if they push in
a few weeks wouldn't that be bleeding
into january i don't see marvel or sony
wanting to release spider-man during
january granted we're living in very
different times pre-pandemic january was
known as dumping [ __ ] so i don't think
that's the same rule anymore now because
we are in this weird unprecedented time
but it still doesn't strike me as i'd
want to release spider-man no way home
in january itself now anything uh worst
case i feel they probably pushed in
february yeah or something because you
would still want to mark it on and
capitalize on the holiday crowds you
know in january everyone's like tapped
out after all that stuff you know we'll
see you know and maybe with the dust
variant as being so bad and people are
bonding together during the holidays and
we see a surge maybe they might have to
push it more there's a whole lot of
factors here that we don't we no one
knows well
no one no one knows
now cinemacon is coming up in a week and
sony is set up to start off the very
first day and they are supposed to show
exclusive footage of their upcoming
projects which obviously spider-man no
way home is and since the fact that the
trailer is being dubbed means that it's
complete that means that they have a
full trailer ready to show at cinemacon
so it could be very possible that they
are going to show the trailer a week
from today but remember they're not
going to release the trailer to the
public they're just going to show it to
people inside of cinemacon we don't know
we don't know
that's not going to stop people from
going on the internet and telling us
what they saw so at the very least we
should have at least a description for
the spider-man no way home teaser
trailer next monday if they do indeed
show the trailer i really think that
they showed at cinemacon they're going
to release it to the public i think this
will be a different case because this
trailer has been
so hyped so secret there's been non-stop
speculation they know it they
i obviously know it i think the last
thing they'd want is to show the trailer
at cinemacon and then just have the
whole description leak out and then we
get it a week later yeah yeah yeah if
anything they just want to hype people
up knowing that it's there oh pretty
soon it'll be out and then this probably
the same day especially if they're
dubbing it now you know they seem to
want it to get as many people as
possible but at this point i wouldn't be
surprised either way
if because that's an economy comes out a
week later i won't be surprised now some
good news is that there are a bunch of
rumors going around right now that we
should be getting the hawkeye trailer
this month or at the latest at the emmys
now this makes perfect sense because
right now the release date for hawkeye
is supposed to be november 24th of this
year yeah we need to travel about three
months away from it which means we're
about due for a trailer for it
definitely it has already begun shang
chi is about to start so the promotion
for hawkeye should be able to pick up
pretty soon here so keep an eye out for
that hawkeye trailer we're also most
likely to get a new eternals trailer
relatively soon with the release of
rumors have it right now that before
shang chi plays in the movie theaters
during the previews there will be an
eternals trailer attached to it in fact
there's actually been word that some
theaters have already begun to play some
new eternals footage before certain
movies but it's believed that a full new
trailer showing new footage is going to
be before shanghai i saw the trailer for
eternals when i saw free guy on imax
and
wow
absolutely
gorgeous like imax is the way to go for
turtles because i really love the way
the trailer felt just watch it on a
computer or a phone but to watch that
trailer imax was like stunning to me so
yeah i can't wait now the trailer for
miss marvel is also rumored to be coming
either during the emmys or disney plus
day if it comes in two thousand twenty
probably gonna get broken kind of up in
the air on whether or not it is going to
release in 2021 but an executive at
disney did say that it was a 2021
feature but we'll have to see about that
however if it is a 2021 feature
obviously we're going to get the trailer
relatively soon the emmys coming up on
september 19th would be a perfect
opportunity for marvel to release a
couple of trailers for their new disney
plushies
so keep an eye out for them
last but not least a lot of people have
been asking me about doctor strange and
the multiverse of madness when we can
expect to see a trailer if we can expect
to see that trailer in 2021 and i say
yes i do think it's winning
a trailer for multiverse of madness
with spiderman no way home the two
movies are very directly connected it
comes out in december and i do really
think that the post-credits scene for
spider-man no way home is going to be
about doctor strange i mean spider-man
know at home already as it is is going
to feature doctor strange as a main
character is going to play a very
important part so it just makes sense
that the post-credits scene would have
something to do with his movie and this
is why i believe that the trailer could
be attached to it or sometime quickly
after yeah i don't think doctor strange
multiverse of manus is coming out this
year
with the way things have been releasing
with trailers with marvel and such i i
highly doubt i mean i'd be more than
happy to be wrong about that guess that
i'm making
but from everything the way the
trajectory has been going and the way
how things are still up in the air i
don't know i i just highly doubt it
would come out and not be talking this
far ahead of the release doesn't seem
likely to me no not even with spider-man
now the teaser is going to have to be
pretty vague especially if you have to
watch the events of spider-man no way
home to really realize what's happening
but since multiverse of madness comes
out on march 25th of 2022 three months
after spider-man no way home they can't
wait until everybody watches it to drop
the first trailer they have to drop it
sooner than that so it's most likely
coming in 2021 if not at the latest very
early 2022. and those are the trailers
that we are all keeping our eyes out for
right now obviously spider-man no way
home being the biggest one and all
exciting nonetheless and speaking of
exciting news it has been reported that
jonathan majors has begun filming his
kang the conqueror scenes for ant-man 3
ant-man and the wasp quantum mania and i
think everybody knows what this means we
are about to get some pretty cool leaks
typically when everything starts filming
things get out they've done a pretty
decent job on spider-man no way home in
fact i think only one photo has leaked
that has dr strange in it the other
marvel has released themselves i'm not
sure i'd want a kang leak photo though
it's not the same as the moon knight one
because that's a full-on costume and i
feel like maybe there's going to be some
cgi updates to the moon knight costume
as they are with most of the marvel
characters but with kang specifically
that
really puts itself in a position if
there's a king leak set photo of people
going i don't know about this this looks
terrible when i'm like i feel like kang
and set himself will need some like real
good post updates before you know you i
don't want people to make that opinion
of gay before
they actually get an official
yeah
that's that's the one uh one little
skepticism i have about getting a gang
set photo i'll still look at it and i'll
still check it out obviously i'm not
gonna we're just not gonna look at it
yeah spoil it for ourselves gotta
nitpick it along with everyone else as
he mentioned his other variants are a
lot more evil than him so this king is
going to be a lot different in fact he
who remains wasn't kang at all he was
peaceful he was actually trying to help
despite his unusual methods but kang is
only going to want to conquer and he is
going to be much worse and i'm hoping
that he gets his traditional purple and
green costume so that's what i'm on the
lookout for right now some leaked photos
of king the conqueror and ant-man and
the wasp quantomania and it sure does
seem like since king is the master of
time travel and this is ant-man and the
wasp quantum mania king at least
harnessed some of the powers of the
quantum realm for time travel kang does
use specific devices that allow him to
time travel in the comics but who knows
in the mcu the quantum realm is probably
the key to everything so i'll be excited
to see some leaked photos of either a
time traveling chair or throne or a ship
of some sort and i really think that
ant-man 3 is going to be a pretty big
movie and ant-man is about to become a
very very prominent avenger so let me
know what you think about all this news
in the comments down below and besides
spider-man no way home because i know
everybody's most excited for that
trailer what trailer are you most
excited for don't forget to like the
video and subscribe and hit that
notification
the latest news for live updates
twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching we'll forward sam
raymond man multiverse and madness
yeah that's the one right there dude
i'm excited that's multiverse all right
warm well i gotta pick your ass up in
about an hour um but guys what did you
think about this video which trailer
other than spiderman no way home are you
most anticipating yourselves be sure to
subscribe hit that like button subscribe
to cosmic wonder as well
look out for our thoughts on chongqi
we'll catch you guys soon
[Music]